I do want to point out
the title of the Washington Post article
Target stores see more bomb threats over
Pride Merchants wrong that's wrong it's
over them removing private merchandise
but you see how they're lying yeah yeah
over Pride merchandise it's such a
manipulative uh that is an outright lie
they did not see bomb threats over Pride
merchandise they didn't they they saw it
exactly they saw a bomb they did not get
bomb threats for the pride merchandise
they got bomb threats for removing the
foreign
until around 60 70 through the story
before mentioning that it was actually
lgbtq people who who were claiming to
have done it this is how the media lies
it is a lie that headline is factually
false and how many people are going to
see that headline and share it and say
this is why we're not safe in this
country the right wing is coming after
us